soon as something negative happens
people tend to blame it on Nazar or the
evil eye so my question is what is the
meaning of the evil eye in the Quran
compared to the knowledge we have from
our cultures you're not going to like
it just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends may Allah bless you guys Ramadan
Mubarak hope it's going well for you
hope it's a new beginning for you
staying away from sins building new
habits praying Salah may Allah bless you
guys in guys so this video I'm going to
be doing I came across no man Alik
Khan's video our brother may Allah bless
and preserve him and protect him um from
evil eye and all kind of stuff today's
topic is about evil eye in we're going
to go to the video uh where he's um made
a video and I agree he some he has some
very valid points but I just believe
that um there's certain points he makes
as if evil eye is not what we think it
is and there is ample evidence ample
evidence to show that evil eyes H not
that I'm saying he denies it but what he
talks about and the way he makes it seem
uh I don't agree with but again brother
and sisters it's Ramadan there are
people who who are refuting him and
breaking their fast with his flesh so
let's fear Allah subhana T we are
fasting he's our brother he can make
mistakes it's fine there's so much
benefit he brings to the um there's so
much he does for the um with this Quran
bringing people people's hearts to the
Quran so please please let be that in
mind in here's the video Let's watch for
oursel and dissect where we agree with
him and where we disagree with him inah
soon as something negative happens
people tend to blame it on Nazar all the
evil eye so my question is what is the
meaning of the evil eye in the Quran
compared to the knowledge we have from
our cultures I am not convinced that we
have interpreted the Comm the common
interpretation of theth involving the
evil eye is interpreted properly in my
opin is referring to jealousy can have
really bad consequences but not that if
I stare at someone with laser focus they
will fall down the stairs or you know
you you developed uh I developed really
bad allergies yesterday because the
first day somebody didn't say Mah when
they saw they saw my PowerPoint
presentation no because if if was really
that powerful then every time a country
elects a presid that the country doesn't
like everybody should just get together
for party and just and then they she
just start melting as they speak
like and no nobody gave like nobody
received more than the prophet of Allah
s alai wasallam right uh the thing with
the idea of uh you know um oh you you
were you were you dressed up for a
wedding and then you look really nice
but you didn't say masah or somebody
else didn't say m even worse okay you
said it you're
like but when you got to the wedding
somebody in your corner was like oh she
looks ni some old lady and she didn't
say and somebody else pulled her the
other direction and now all of a sudden
has changed and now you know you're just
going to develop this skin rash that's
going to make like boils on your
forehead and you're like that old lady I
got I got at the no that's in my opinion
that is superstition this is this this
is a kind of religion that it's it's an
exaggerated extreme that has gone too
far and we've turned our religion into
the superstitious stuff and it's just
not something true to the spirit of the
Quran now first I want to start with the
points that he made which are very very
true what we've done with the evil eye
we've turned it into an absolute
Superstition now what does that mean now
what it means not just Superstition like
what we've done is it's like we have
made it seem as if everything that
happens to us evil eye evil eye evil eye
EV that happened evil eye that happened
EV eye this happened evil eye oh I trip
evil eye this everything is connected to
that and sometimes people go to the
level where it can be B the sh by making
it seem as if evil ey is stronger than
what Allah deed or stronger than
Allah so many people blame evil ey for
everything and anything instead of being
Afflicted going through hardships I went
through something couple four five years
ago maybe more than that yeah alhamd I
know it's cuz I was not doing my the
morning and evening I was not doing it
yes I was praying I was doing my ET but
the is so key that's why it made sense
to me Subhan Allah as a public figure
who's there there are people that don't
like me there are jealous Envy not I'm
saying there anything to be jealous
about not don't get twisted but I'm just
saying there could be jealousy there can
be envy they could be hatred they could
be whatever for that matter yeah the
enemies of Islam you need to protect
yourself especially in the public sphere
so therefore there's certain things that
I agree with him where it's become a
Superstition where any little thing
happens evil eye maybe it's a test from
Allah you're going through hardship
because Allah said you're going to be
tested why does it have to be evil eye
why does it have to be magic why does it
have to be S everything connected to
that so I agree with num our brother may
Allah bless and preserve him and uh um
and he's not infallible in the human
being and he you know makes mistakes
like I believe this was a mistake from
his part so let's bear that in mind now
coming to the issue of evil eye evil eye
the prophet sallallahu alhi said evil I
is H and if anything was to overcome the
decree of Allah yes with the permission
of Allah it would be evil eye by not
that evil eye has its own power to do
that no it's by the permission of like
it's with the permission of Allah that
they harm people and they can only harm
people with the permission of Allah subh
if Allah will it bear that in mind black
magic and evil eye is not a super entity
another godah that is no we're not
seeing that now there are some evidences
that we're going to bring which one one
of them is very very powerful because if
evil I was like nor Alan our brother was
saying that it's just something physical
or somebody can cause you hatred you
know with their jealousy Etc then what
about this Hadith what do we say about
thisi let's let's read for ourself
related to me from Malik that
Muhammed h heard his father say my
father H did a
at he removed theba he had on
while was watching and sah was a man
with beautiful white skin am said to him
I have never seen anything like what I
have seen today not even the skin of a
virgin sahal fell ill on the spot or
some ntion say he he he went unconscious
and his condition grew worse Somebody
went to the messenger of Allah s
wasallam and told him that sah was ill
and could not go with him the message of
Allah may Allah be pleased with him and
Grant him peace came to him and S and
sah told him what happened with Amir the
mess of Allah may Allah be pleased with
him s am said why does one of you kill
his brother why did you not say may
Allah bless
you the evil eye is true do wo from it
did wo from it and sah went with went to
the messenger of Allah may Allah be be
pleased with him uh and there was
nothing wrong with him so now if evil
eye is that somebody has evil eye you
know jealousy Etc and he wants and and
that means that that causes him to harm
you
physically then why did the prophet
peace upon him tell him which is the
Sunnah that you do wo with the person
who gave you the EV ey yes you use that
wo you do it with that because if the
harm is physical if it's going to cause
you physic he didn't do anything
physical he just said something didn't
say yeah and the person Ed so do you see
here our dear brother that brother no
man Al Khan that it doesn't follow you
know it doesn't follow if that's the
case if you're saying that evil ey is
you know I understand the other extreme
you're talking about but now then you're
going to another extreme which is oh it
doesn't exist Etc and there's many
scholars Etc many scholars have you know
made it clear that evil evil eye in the
aspect is real and it is true yeah and
there's many examples I can give you so
let's go to another one for example I
abas reported that Allah's messenger
sallallahu alhi wasallam said the
influence of evil eye is a fact if
anything would proceede the destiny it
would be the influence of an evil eye
and when you are asked to asked to take
bath as a cure from the influence of an
evil eye you should take a bu there you
go it was narrated from AA that the
prophet sallallahu alhi wasallam said
commanded her to recite Rya to treat the
evil now if it's just physical that I
argue say have an evil eye to someone
and I want to go and harm him physically
how is Rukia going to cure that how how
would Rukia cure that so if somebody
felt ill and it was because of me not
liking him and I'm enous and jealous of
him and I want to go and harm him but
they do Ria what how's Ria going to I
don't understand how's Ria going to stop
me from harming him if I'm going to go
and punch him how's going like do you
get what I'm trying to say so it doesn't
follow
again ja reported the messenger of Allah
sallu alhi wasallam say that a a great
many from my nation who die after the
Judgment decree and Providence of Allah
die by the evil eye Alani graded this
Hassan yes okay so it's Hassan it's you
know it's acceptable yeah so the point
here is this that it is H and there's
many where the Prophet said there are so
many people in the graves because of
evil eye so now what does that mean you
know then you know it's if it's evil ey
then that means these people what were
they were killed then why is there
no yeah why is there no kasas for this
then because it's evil if evil I kill
them that means these people have been
killed physically being killed they've
gone and somebody killed them Etc no
they were dead because of evil eye
otherwise each person would know the
culprit do you get what I'm trying to
say in that sense but we know that's not
the case we know that it is because the
prophet P saying many people are in the
grave because of that now can is it a
reality that somebody can hate someone
so much that they want to go and harm
them yes that's envy and jealousy and
that can cause you to take physical
action to do that but not everybody is
um brave enough or or want to go and do
that there's consequences to that so
evil eye in the Supernatural world is
it's it's it's it's a fact uh so I think
the matter of the woodo thing makes it
categorically clear U so yeah in not
show guys please please be wary of that
in do your morning and evening is very
very important guys Subhan Allah yeah to
protect you from evil eye uh jealousy
Envy black magic physical harm with the
permission of Allah subh unless other
Wills otherwise and if Allah Wills
otherwise and you are touched by evil
life whatever it is it is what Allah
decreed Subhan Allah it's as simple as
that and sometimes things happen where
it's not it's just physical you're just
ill whatever is for that matter it's
from Allah stop blaming black magic say
my cousin in Pakistan or that Uncle in
this country did this please that
becomes superstitious that's all I
wanted to say inah may Allah bless you
guys inah brothers and sisters do not
forget that we are at Salam trying to
teach new Muslim and born Muslims how to
pray Salah please please guys inshah we
want to teach 10,000 plus people this
year how to pray Salah you can be the
first time 100 pounds can teach 10 to 30
people how to do woo For the First Time
how to pray Salah for the first time not
only that we are teaching them
F first time ever brother and sisters
you can be a part of this Amazing
Project go to the link in the
description box below and donate
whatever you can hope you enjoyed the
video please free your tongues from
backbiting our brother he can he's a
human being he can make mistakes he does
great benefits to the
umam before is better than this world
and everything in it then what is the
reward for the one who not only taught
them how to pray Salah but also the
first chapter in the
Quran what if I told you that because of
your donations we will be teaching
thousands of people around the world to
learn how to pra Salah brothers and
sisters we only need 100 people to give
£100 £100 can help teach 10 to 30 people
learn how to praise Salah and memorize
Al fa for the first time ever imagine
you are the reason for people like
Michael like Katrina like Trisha like me
who learn how to pray for the first time
ever with us thanks to your donations
the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said anyone that calls someone
to good will get the same reward without
anything being taken away from them
click the link below and donate
[Music]
now